can you maybe describe
what
what does the prayer represent what is
the actual practice of prayer like what
is the process like
sure so prayer is the central pillar if
you will of Islam
um
it is the life of the believer
um encapsulated
in to a very specific Act of devotion
that's done at least five times a day so
there are different types of prayer
there's prayer there's supplication so
the the five daily prayers are called
Salah which is the obligatory prayers
and then beyond that there are voluntary
prayers that are done uh throughout the
day as well so you can pray before and
after the obligatory prayers and then
there are other times of the day that
you can pray also and the best prayer
voluntary prayers at night in the middle
of the night because it's the time that
you're closest to God uh sincere away
from the eyes of people uh Just In the
Still of the Night and you'd pray in a
similar way with the standing and the
Bowing and the prostration reciting the
Quran and then you have supplication and
words of remembrance that you are to do
throughout the day
um between all of that so when people
say do you pray five times a day I say
at least five times a day
um what are the words this application
do they come from the Quran or do they
come from your own heart or do they
where do they come from so basically you
say Allahu Akbar
uh which means I'm going to kill you
right
or so they say right
no God is greater you start off with
that an expression of God's greatness
and then you recite the opening chapter
of the Quran which is uh known as the
first chapter of the Quran in the name
of God the most compassionate the most
merciful all Praises be to God the Lord
of all the worlds most compassionate
most merciful Master of the day of
judgment you alone we worship and from
you alone we seek help guide us to the
straight path the path of those who have
earned your favor not those who have
earned your wrath nor those who have
gone astray so that's a translation of
the first chapter the opening chapter of
the Quran which is known as so we recite
that in every one of the units of Prayer
um and then after that we recite
something else from the Quran so some
other portion of the Quran and then we
say Allahu Akbar once again
God is greater we go into bowing and in
bowing we say subhanallah
subhanallah
which means glory be to God the almighty
glory be to God the almighty glory be to
God the almighty and then you come back
up and you say
God has heard the one who has praised
him
and then the response is
and To You O Lord belongs all praise
and then we go into prostration and
prostration is at the heart of the
prayer
and it is the most beautiful portion of
the prayer and it is
the most beloved position
for a servant of God and that which is
most pleasing to God
it's when you say at that point
subhanallah all glory be to God the most
high all glory be to God the most high
so while you put yourself in the lowest
position you acknowledge God being the
most high and the prophet peace and
blessings be upon him said that the
closest that a person is to God is when
they are in prostration that is the time
that your supplications are most
precious and beloved that is the time
that you can cry your heart out that is
the time that you really feel a sense of
great closeness and Devotion to God and
as I was telling you earlier it's a time
that your your mind is under your heart
for a change right the only positioned
physical position that your mind is
actually under your heart and you really
have a chance to pour your emotions out
and to connect deeply to God it's the
prayer of all of the prophets uh Jesus
peace be upon Him is described even
biblically as falling on his face in
prayer and so it really is uh I think
the most intimate moment that you get
with God and the deepest part of the
prayer the word Masjid
which is mosque in Arabic means place of
sujood place of prostration so think of
the rest of prayer as an introduction to
that particular part of the prayer where
you really immerse yourself not that you
shouldn't be immersed in your prayer
throughout but when you're in sujood
when you're in prostration that's where
you're really closest and most connected
to God so we do that
and so some prayers are two units uh
well the first prayer of the day
which is Before Sunrise the earliest
prayer is two units
um the second prayer which is around
noon is four units and then afternoon
another four units and then the sunset
prayer is three units and then the
evening prayer is four units so each
prayer has a different number of units
to it and some voluntary prayers that
surround it when you come back up you
express also a form of greeting towards
God and channeling your prayers and your
blessings towards God you reiterate the
shahada which is the first pillar of
Islam I testify that there is only one
God and that Muhammad is his servant and
messenger and then you read what's
called Salah ibrahimia which is the
abrahamic prayer so you send peace and
blessings upon Muhammad and his family
and Abraham and his family
Abraham peace be upon Him is really at
the core of this religion and so at the
prayer at the end of the prayer you you
send peace and blessings and prayers
upon again both Muhammad and his family
and Abraham and his family
and then you have another chance to make
some of your own personal prayers and
then you say assalamu alaikum
peace Beyond to you in the mercy of God
to your right peace Beyond to you in the
mercy of God to your left and that means
everything and everyone to your right
everyone and everything to your left so
you imagine a congregation
uh when you're in worship right you're
you're sending that to the angels and
the human beings next to you your fellow
worshipers next to you
and you'll even say you'll seek
forgiveness from God afterwards there
are supplications that surround the
prayer
and you will say
that oh Allah oh God you are peace and
from you is peace unto you belongs all
glory and uh all praise
almost to say that you received
something in this prayer that you
receive a great sense of inner peace and
now you're spreading that right so as it
really comes into you then you can give
you can give to the world around you
what you generate in your own heart
and in prayer you generate a great sense
of Tranquility a great sense of peace
the Quran says verily in the remembrance
of God do hearts find contentments
and prayer is an exercise in the
remembrance of God
um that is again obligatory five times a
day
no matter where you are so anywhere in
the world anywhere you find yourself in
your life in in different life
circumstances anywhere yeah so outside
coffee shop in the grass outside
as it did a few days ago yeah uh so any
anywhere at all and that means airports
included given the context of our
previous conversation of
uh hatred towards people of Muslim faith
that means
you probably through the practice of
prayer it attracts people that hate I've
attracted curiosity hate I've had people
walk up to me like hey man you're okay
you know in the herbs everything so most
probably these conversations of
curiosity and the opportunity to
actually uh talk about the values that
you representing and I try to make it a
point to tell people if I'm about to
pray in front of them so like you know
in the airport let's say for example go
to the corner next to a gate yeah and if
there are people sitting there like hey
I'm about to engage in a prayer I hope
you don't mind they'll really appreciate
the courtesy most of the time
um but no I mean any when those five
times come in and they're kind of
Windows right
um we have to pray and uh
uh that means at work that means at
school that means when you're when
you're traveling although there are some
concessions that allow you to combine
prayers at uh certain times when you're
traveling for example
but even then uh you're gonna have to
pray and
um I think that
what that does
to
bring you back to God
no matter what you're doing
it's actually you know you think of it
this way you're in a meeting you're
engaged in something you're really
stressed out and you also have the
ablution before the prayer where you
wash up wash your face wash your limbs
and engage in prayer
what it does for you
and anchoring you in something more
meaningful
when you are in the turmoil of a lot of
times what's not so meaningful
uh is incredible and so it's a gift from
God
and it is an obligation it's something
that we have to do as Muslims
but if you actually learn its Essence
then
it can feel more like a joy than it is
an obligation
and then you're called to at night
especially again the night prayer is a
big part of who we are as Muslims waking
up in the last part of the night
the prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
said that the the best prayer and the
best fasting was of that of David peace
be upon him so we think of David Prophet
David he's a prophet in Islam as well
I'm sure you'll ask me about the whole
concept of prophethood you're hearing
Abraham and David and others right so
David peace be upon him he said that
David used to fast every other day and
he used to pray the last third of the
night he'd stand up and pray in the last
third of the night
so fasting is a big part of Who We Are
and praying in the last third of the
night
meaning before that early morning prayer
you know waking up if you can at 4 AM 4
30 a.m 5 A.M
and praying even for a few minutes
um there's something in the serenity of
the night
that
can unlock a new a sense of inner joy
and peace that nothing else in the world
can give you
and again that pulls you away from all
the turmoil of day-to-day life
uh if it's little things or if it's big
things you just pulls it pulls you out
of it to remember what is more important
than life so when we think about access
uh in the last third of the night we're
taught that God says is there anyone
seeking forgiveness that I may forgive
them
is there anyone seeking Refuge that I
may Grant it to them is there anyone
asking for anything that I may give it
to them so whatever you're calling upon
him with at that time he's responding to
you in a way that befits him and so it's
closeness as well and uh you would think
that you sleep less so
you're probably more cranky but
um the happiest people in the world are
the people that stand up in that last
start of the night and pray I mean
there's a deeply meditative
contemplative
aspect to it that I that I think
um
probably strengthens your sleep if
anything else once you return to it
there you go see people underestimate
that there's a great sage in Islam he
was asked he said how come the people
who pray at night are the most beautiful
of people and they're they're fresh in
the day it doesn't make sense and he
said because they secluded themselves
with the most merciful and he dressed
them in his light
and so there's a there's a there's a
beauty that it generates
um and that's why we're to Aspire to
that really as as Believers that's kind
of your highest thing like don't just
pray the five prayers if you can pray at
night pray at night and connect at that
time well a good friend of mine Andrew
huberman who's in your scientist from
Stanford he's a big he's upset he has a
amazing podcast called humor and lab but
he's also a scholar of sleep
uh among many other things and so I
would love him to he probably knows the
science on this too
there's probably good signs that
actually studies uh uh practicing
Muslims to see what
um the the benefits of sleep I would
love to actually um see what that says
we we have amazing I don't want to cut
you off yeah we have amazing hygiene
because of how much we have to wash up
for prayer and it's great for our limbs
as well right
um you know and that's one of the added
benefits right it's good for us worship
that we do is not torturous it's
actually good for us however the core
objective of worship has to remain that
it's something you do out of worship and
something you do out of an a sense of
obligation gratitude to God not because
of those things like I'm not going to
fast because it's good for my health but
I know it's good for my health to fast
but it's pretty cool when you walk into
them I'll share this with you there is a
man he was a a scholar from Turkey an
Islamic scholar from turkey and he had
visited Us in Dallas and he was 108
years old and he could still pray bowing
and prostrating
I mean his Limbs and you think about
that like someone at that age still
being able to do that so I'm sure it's
good for your limbs it's good for your
health good for your gut good for your
sleep good for your mind I think the
mind one is is the really one we've been
talking about and that's really really
the really the big one and in the in the
small day-to-day psychological sense in
the big philosophical sense of what it
means to be a human being